the senator from vermont became the
unlikeliest of fashion icons at the
inauguration
by wearing woolly mittens made from
repurposed sweaters and recycled plastic
bottles
made by school teacher i was just
sitting there trying to keep
warm trying to pay attention to what was
going on
within hours the image of bernie sanders
was everywhere repurposed into days of
hilarious content on social media
with the senator appearing in major
films historical moments and even the al
jazeera newsroom
chairman sanders merchandise quickly
sold out his political action committee
has raised 1.8 million dollars for area
charities
including meals on wheels an
organization that delivers food to
senior citizens
who live alone toby king was inspired to
make a doll of the senator it fetched
40 000 on ebay it's very inspiring
like how no matter your political views
one of his main goals is to help people
how can you not like somebody who wants
to donate to meals on wheels
you know what i'm saying so he inspired
me to do the same thing
50 million americans including one in
four children
are food insecure demand on food
pantries has spiked
during the pandemic so any effort to
feed the hungry is certainly welcome
at a time where help is needed more than
ever andrew chappelle
al jazeera